Welcome back.
I'm now going to introduce
you to a new tool for
solving derivatives.
Really between this rule, which
is the product rule, and the
chain rule and just knowing a
lot of function derivatives,
you'll be ready to tackle
almost any derivative problem.
Let's start with
the chain rule.
Let's say that f of x is equal
to h of x times g of x.
This is the product rule.
In the chain rule it was f of
x is equal to h of g of x.
Right?
I don't know if you
remember that.
In this case, f of x is equal
to h of x times g of x.
If that's the case, then f
prime of x is equal to the
derivative of the first
function times a second
function plus the first
function times the derivative
of the second function.
Pretty straightforward.
Let's apply it.
Let's say that-- I don't like
this brown color, let me pick
something more pleasant.
Maybe mauve.
Let's say that f of x is equal
to 5x to the fifth minus x to
the seventh times 20x squared
plus 3x to them mine 7.
So one way we could have
done it, we could just
multiply this out.
This wouldn't be too bad, and
then take the derivative
like any polynomial.
But let's use this product rule
that I've just shown you.
So the product rules that says,
let me take the derivative of
the first expression, or h of x
if we wanted to map
it into this rule.
The derivative of that is
pretty straightforward.
5 times 5 is 25.
25x to the fourth, right?
Then minus 7, x to the sixth.
We're just going to multiply it
times this second expression,
doing nothing different to it.
Maybe I'll just do it
in a different color.
Times 20x plus 3x minus 7.
And then to that we will
add the derivative of
this second function.
The derivative of that second
function is 40x minus
21x to the minus eighth.
And that times this
first function.
I guess I'll switch
back to mauve, I think
you get the point.
5x to the fifth minus
x to the seventh.
All we did here was we said OK,
f of x is made of these two
expressions and they are
multiplied by each other.
If I want to take the
derivative of it, I take the
derivative of the first one and
multiply it by the second one.
And then I add that to the
derivative of the second
one and multiply it
by the first one.
Let's do some more examples
and I think that will
hit the point home.
Clear image.
Change the colors and
I'm back in business.
Let me think of a good problem.
Let me do another one like
this, and then I'll actually
introduce ones and the product
rule and the chain rule.
So let's say that f of x is
equal to 10x to the third plus
5x squared minus 7 times
20x to the eighth minus 7.
Then we say f prime of x,
what's the derivative of
this first expression.
It's 30x squared plus 10x.
And I just multiply it times
this expression, right?
20x to the eighth minus 7.
And I add that to the
derivative of this second
expression, this is all on one
line but I ran out of space,
160x to the seventh, right?
8 times 20 is 160.
And then the derivative
of 7 is zero.
So it's just 160x to
the seventh times this
first expression.
10x to the third plus 5x
squared minus seven.
There we go.
And you could simplify it.
You could multiply this out
if you wanted or you could
distribute this out if you
wanted, maybe try to
condense the terms.
But that's really just algebra.
So this is using
the product rule.
I'm going to do one more
example where I'll show you,
I'm going to use the product
and the chain rule and
I think this will
optimally confuse you.
I want to make sure
I have some space.
Here I'm going to use a
slightly different notation.
Instead of saying f of x and
then what's f prime of x, I'm
going to say y is equal to x
squared plus 2x to the fifth
times 3x to the minus three
plus x squared to the minus 7.
And I want to find the rate at
which y changes relative to x.
So I want to find dy over dx.
This is just like, if this
was f of x, it's just
like saying f prime of x.
This is just a [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
notation.
So what do I do in
the chain rule?
First I want the
derivative of this term.
Let me use colors to make
it not too confusing.
So what's the derivative
of this term?
We are going to use
the chain rule first.
So we take the derivative of
the inside which is 2x plus 2
and multiply times
the derivative of the
larger expression.
But we keep x squared plus 3x
there so it's times 5 times
something to the fourth.
And that something is
x squared plus 2x.
So there we took the derivative
of this first term right here
and then the product rules says
we take the derivative of the
first term, we just multiply
it by the second term.
So the second term is just 3x
to the minus 3 plus x squared
and all that to the minus 7.
We did that and then to that we
add plus the derivative of this
second term times
this first term.
We're going to use the
chain rule again.
What's the derivative
of the second term?
I'll switch back to
the light blue.
Light blue means the derivative
of one of the terms.
So we take the derivative of
the inside, the derivative of
inside is minus 3 times 3 is
minus 9, x go down one to
the minus 4, plus 2x.
And now we take the derivative
of the whole thing.
Times minus 7 times something
to the minus 8, and that
something is this inside.
3x to the minus 3
plus x squared.
And then we multiply this
thing, this whole thing which
is the derivative of the second
term times the first term.
Times, and I'm just going to
keep going, times x squared
plus 2x to the fifth.
So this is a really, I
mean you might want to
simplify at this point.
You can take this minus
7 and multiply it
out and all of that.
But I think this
gives you the idea.
And if you have to multiply
this out and then do the
derivative if it's just a
polynomial, this would
take you forever.
But using the chain rule,
you're actually able to, even
though we ended up with a
pretty complicated answer,
we got the right answer.
And now we could actually
evaluate the slope of this very
complicated function at any
point just by substituting the
point into this fairly
complicated expression.
But at least we could do it.
I think you're going to find
that the chain and the product
rules become even more useful
once we start doing derivatives
of expressions other
than polynomials.
I'm going to teach you about
trigonometric functions and
natural log and logarithm
and exponential functions.
Actually, I'll probably do that
in the next presentation.
So I will see you soon.